(romantic guitar music)
(laughing)
- I have a feeling that
novellas are similar
to American soap operas.
- Someone's always sleeping with somebody,
somebody killed somebody's uncle.
- People too sexy for what
they're doing, is that possible?
- [Voiceover] I feel like
this is just a really
heightened version of a lot
of Bravo's reality shows.
- Their makeup is just a little too much.
(laughing) Like, that eyeshadow game.
- They're all wearing like,
cartoon clothes, you know?
- I'm 20 seconds into this show,
and already, my mind is blown.
- And why are there so
many closeups? (laughing)
- This lady is trying to attack
a small girl in a wheelchair
because she was...
Oh! The wheelchair got knocked over!
- It kind of reminds me of when Solange
went after Jay-Z in that elevator.
- Oh, she killed the old lady! Oh, (beep)!
- Oh, no! She has the scissors.
Oh, what's going to happen? Oh my god.
- I think he's dying
because she stabbed him
in the arm, which, like, come on.
- People have entered the room
to watch this kid bleed to death.
- Everyone's just crying
and yelling and screaming,
and they just keep doing
closeups of everyone's face.
Just like, ah!
- This is basically like
WWE, but in a Latin version.
- The same two people died in
like a matter of four minutes.
- [Voiceover] "La Usurpadora",
so it's basically like
their version of Mary-Kate and Ashley"?
- These intros are too much for me.
Like I would have already flipped
the channel at this point.
- Characters are either
like, not paying attention
to the camera at all, or
just looking deep into it.
- There's like this
really ridiculous music
playing in the background.
- I can't count, there's
been like 20 characters.
- This is also long, like,
why is this intro still going?
- I like the musical cues.
I wish I could have that in real life,
just when I walk in the room.
- Loco, I know that.
- They really like mirrors on this show.
Like, if there's a camera angle
on one person, there's
a mirror behind them,
where you could like
still see the other guy.
- She just did the thing where you like,
you're facing away from someone,
and he's talking at you back
here, and then you just go...
- She's like, "Let me give
you this one last kiss."
"Remember me fondly,
because you ain't never
"going to find a (beep) like this."
- Rubbing his thumbs on her chin,
because he's going in for a kiss.
But she's like, "Oh,no.
You're goatee looks gross."
- She looks like she does
not want this kiss at all.
It's making me really uncomfortable.
- I don't like one sided kissing.
- Like, you know you're supposed to go 90,
and she's supposed to go 10?
He definitely went like 95
and she went five and it was strange.
- I mean, I get why
people get hooked to these
because, literally, anything can happen.
(romantic guitar music)